las fuerzas armadas de mianmar muestran
su músculo militar tanques cañones
misiles marcan el ritmo de la ceremonia
del día de las fuerzas armadas el
general mina online pasa revista a sus
tropas desde el golpe de estado
concentra todos los poderes el día de
las fuerzas armadas conmemora la
resistencia de los militares contra la
ocupación japonesa en 1942 sin embargo
este año la demostración de fuerza
parece dirigirse al monumento de
desobediencia civil no debemos aceptar
las reivindicaciones por la vía del
terrorismo ya que pueden perturbar la
tranquilidad del país cuando levantemos
las disposiciones del estado de alarma
organizaremos elecciones libres y justas
para transferir las responsabilidades
gubernamentales pero sin un calendario
fijo y frente a la represión mortal del
ejército
los manifestantes persisten con las
protestas este 27 de marzo se han
organizado nuevas movilizaciones la
policía respondió con fuego real que
causó decenas de muertos el día anterior
con
vista puesta en esta jornada el ejército
había difundido un mensaje a través de
la televisión del estado no mueran en
vano según distintas asociaciones desde
el golpe de estado del 1 de febrero más
de 300 personas han fallecido y
alrededor de 3000 han sido detenidas
mientras tanto la presión de la
comunidad internacional no tiene
demasiada incidencia cada resolución de
la onu es bloqueada por rusia o china en
el consejo de seguridad de hecho estos
dos países han sido los únicos en mandar
delegaciones para asistir al desfile
militar